hello everyone and welcome to a really
really awesome game uh from the tie
breaks of the round four of the fiji
world cup
2021. uh it's magnus cross and versus
the radoslav
and uh like i said uh the first two
classical games ended in a draw
and now they have to go into tie breaks
so whoever wins uh wins the
entire thing and goes into round five of
the affiliate world cup that's already
happening and the the first rapid game
uh uh
ended in a draw where uh watashi had the
white pieces but now magnus has the
white pieces
and let's see what happens here and this
is a basically a very very sad story
it features um well a very sad story
about a certain piece that
wasn't able to get back into the game uh
something that often happens but here
it's
very very um nicely illustrated so
without further ado let's check it out
magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with
d4 uh sorry about that
we have knight to f6 by radic uh c4 we
have e6
knight to c3 and bishop to b4 so the
nimzo indian defenses on the board
uh and the e3 e3 and queen to c2 are the
two common ways to fight against the
name so indian magnus chooses the e3
also known as the normal line
i think queen to c2 is referred to as
the traditional line i i could be wrong
but i think it is
so here we have castles by black bishop
to d3 and now
c5 striking in the center we have knight
to e2 a3 is also possible you could also
just challenge the bishop right away
but magnus chooses knight to e2 adds
another defender to the c3 square which
will be
of some importance later on we have d5
grabbing more space in the center
c captures on d5 c captures on d4 e
captures on d for end
knight captures on d4 we have castles by
magnus
uh and now knight to c6 uh and here
magnus just trades with knight countries
on the e5 and now
e captures on d5 a queen captures on d5
is
also played here not as much as e
captures on d5 because it's super
complicated
and it's very easy for black to go wrong
for example i'll give you just a very
nice line in case someone plays this
against you
uh if queen captures on d5 we're just
going to challenge the dark square
bishop and once the bishop moves
e7 or d6 we're just going to play knight
to c3 attack the queen here
and now uh well it's just uh easier to
play position for white and also if
black gets greedy and grabs the pawn
here uh
he just loses the game on the spot just
knife the b5 attacks the queen and the
bishop and once the queen moves
we just eliminate the bishop and the
black can never capture back because the
black captures back bishop captures an
h7 check and we
win the queen here captures and queen
captures on d6
so although black can play this it's a
bit easier to play for white so he
captures on d5 is the more preferred
line
we have knight the f4 a very nice square
for the knight also you could add some
pressure to the d5 pawn for example
and bishop back to d6 and the bishop
really has no business being here and
we're going to kick it away with a3 b4
at some point so you can't really keep
an eye on the e1 square
so bishop back to d6 we have bishop to
e3
and now comes bishop captures on f4 and
this is already
a very interesting moment in the game as
uh radik decides to give up the bishop
pair uh
activate his queen with tempo also rook
to e8 uh
you could go for something like this you
could play knights to b4 uh those are
all
possible moves but uh he goes for the
forcing bishop captures bishop captures
and queen to f6 now with pressure on the
bishop
magnus moves back the bishop bishop to
e3 again you can never capture this i
know you guys
already know this but just in case i'm
going to show it once again captures in
bishop captures and h7 wins black's
queen
so the pawn although it's not defended
twice it actually is uh
indirectly so here we have knight to b4
putting pressure on the light square
bishop and the magnus of course
very happy to uh retain his bishop here
goes bishop back to b1 and next you're
going to kick away the knight and you're
going to bring the bishop back into the
game
so here radhik does what he
planned after knight to b4 and that is
bishop to f5 he wants to eliminate
crossing the very strong light square
bishop
and uh you know he will not have to
worry about any weaknesses along this
diagonal so here we have queen to b3
attacking the knight and radic traits
here we have bishop captures rook
captures and
now queen to d6 defending the knight
here with
a3 challenging the knight and now
radic plays knight to a6 which is a very
interesting move because after the
knight moves the b7 pawn
kind of falls but not really and here
you you can choose knight to the a6 or
knight to c6 erratic plays knight to a6
although
knight to c6 is a bit more precise
because white can never capture the pawn
i mean you could but if you capture the
pawn
uh then black has this very very cool
knight
capture sunday for move sort of a piece
sacrifice but not really
because after bishop captures rook after
b8 uh traps the queen but not really
because uh well black white can simply
play bishop to e5 attack black's queen
and now
black can simply win back the piece and
then white gets the c6 square for his
queen so here this is pretty much forced
captures an e5 queen to c6
and the game continues it's a very nice
position uh you can't go after the pawn
because the rook on eight hangs and
uh it's a pretty equal position but
uh you know probably white is to be
preferred for some reasons he does have
the advantage here two against one on
the queen side but black has the central
pass pawn so you know it all depends
whether you prefer to play with
with the uh isolated past pawn or not
most people do uh but okay after a3 we
have knight to a6 and now the idea is
the same you can't really go after the
b7 pawn
if you go after it is the same idea rook
after b8 and now
the queen doesn't really have a square
so you have to give up the dark square
bishop
and once the queen captures it now we
can capture an a6 and it's pretty much
the same thing
black wins back his pawn queen captures
on d4 and it's uh the exact same
pawn setup with the queens being on
different squares uh but of course the
magnus does not capture on b7 i mean why
would he
and um i think that the knight is placed
a little bit better on c6 and uh
this i didn't say this will be a story a
very sad story
uh without a reason so the knight on a6
is
basically what starts this story so here
we have rook b to c1
now magnus uh has some ideas of claiming
the c
file for himself he would of course very
much enjoy doubling up pieces here
uh bishop can come maybe to f4 at some
point to help out with the control of
the c7 square
so queen to d7 now the queen guards the
b7 pawn and the bishop to f4 now
grabbing more control of the c7 square
but the black will not have any of this
he just
counters white's rooks with rook a to c8
we have queen to g3 now with triple
control of the c7 square
but also black does not have a dark
square bishop so you might have some
problems if for example bishop to h6
appears on the board so here
we have f6 and it's a really ugly
position for black because
this knight can never enter the game
look at the pawns here covering covering
uh this is covered three times so you
can't really do anything here
and even if you try to play some like
knight b8 to bring it back with knight
to c6 we're just gonna
capture here once and after captures
we're just gonna pick up the piece
so simple as that so instead after queen
to g3 we have
f6 by black now the queen covers g7 so
no bishop to h6 action
is possible but now uh magnus says okay
there's a weakness
let's let's create more weaknesses so he
plays h4 h5 h6 of course is the idea
uh we have rook capture sun c1 rook
captures and the rook the c8 the radik
wants to eliminate
all of the pieces of the board i haven't
mentioned this but the robot clearly
states it's a rapid game as the two
previous games have been classical time
format
so here magnus captures on c8 queen
captures and now
the beautiful b4 uh it's uh often
that in in games when someone plays b4
you know something beautiful happens
uh but here it's no different the knight
has
no way of entering the game all of these
squares are taken
by the pawns and these squares by the
bishop and by the queen so the knight on
a6 is a very very sad night
and how will how will radic ever
activate it so here we have b5
uh and the magnus just continues with
his plan we have h6
uh h5 preparing h6 we have queen to d7
and now queen to f3 again saying okay
now you can maybe activate your knight
but then i'm just going to capture and
eliminate the d5 pawn and then i have a
pass deep on so you can't really
activate the knight
regardless of what you do we have h6
h6 by black not allowing h6 by white and
now comes queen to c3
so again keeping an eye on the c7 square
and not
allowing black to activate the knight we
have queen to f5 now saying
okay now i'm going to capture the bishop
so you have to do something about that
and magnus just plays
g3 not a problem you don't have to worry
about queen to b1 check it's really
nothing we're just going to play king to
g2
so here queen back to d7 eradic forced
to wait and see
what magnus will do and now queen to c2
with some ideas of maybe queen g6 bishop
captures an h6 and so on
so here king the f8 avoiding such ideas
and now comes queen to h7
so again what do you play here uh well
here
there's really no way for black to make
any any progress
and there's still no way to activate the
knight there is a one move
and that is of course knight to c7 and
this is what radic played but
uh that this is exactly what magnus was
waiting for as there is no way to
the there's no way to activate the
knight but there but
activating the knight is the only way so
feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the only uh well pretty
much winning move for white
that you know wins the game while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
realizing that the queen on d7 is
undefended and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's of course
the bishop captures on h6 and now with
this
spawn eliminated it's only a matter of
time this bishop will move back the pawn
will go to h6 and black's entire
defenses will be ruined
so oh and of course if you capture
you'll lose the queen that goes without
saying
uh so after bishop captures an h6 we
have
queen to g4 now uh maybe you will be
able
to to capture the bishop even though the
knight is now hanging so it's not really
a problem
uh but they just bishop back to e3
everything is defended here the queen
now guards this pawn and h6
is coming so here knight to e6 eradic
hats to give up uh this one pawn to
activate his knight
but now queen to h8 would check h6 was
also a possibility right away king to f7
and now queen to c8 magnus instead of
pushing this pawn
just decides to leave it there and he
says okay now i'm going to give check
start eliminating this pawn play a4
create a pass pawn here
uh pretty much straight forward with
queen to e4
and now comes queen to d7 check this is
unstoppable king the g8 and the queen
captures on a7 we have
knight to g5 black completely
disregarded capturing an h5
and uh he says all right i'm going to
try to uh pose some problems here for
for the white king that's my only option
but
of course the bishop captures on g5
magnus is more than happy to go into
this end game
we have queen to e1 chair king to g2 and
now queen the e for
king the h2 and now f captures on g5 but
now
the b5 pawn is also lost queen to ba to
check the b5 pawn is gone
king to f7 now comes queen to c7 check
magnus first
uh decides to give a few more checks
before capturing the spawn
uh and maybe he's not gonna capture it
at all
because here we have king to f6 now
queen to d6
we have king to f7 and now uh magnus
shows why he is so strong in the end
game because
uh well who wouldn't grab this pawn and
have two connected passports on the
queen side everyone would grab this pawn
there's no
not grabbing this pawn but magnus shows
how simple chess really is he just plays
queen to g6 check
he gives up one of his pawns just to
trade queens and he knows that
this king and pawn end game is winning
that's how that's how uh
you know chess is a fun game so here
queen captures and g6 only move
uh we have h captures and g6 king
captures and now
g4 and this is such a strong move not
allowing black
any squares here but the thing that you
have to realize before trading queens is
that black covers
all of these squares so uh you have no
way of
entering the position with your king but
magnus knows that this is not a problem
because at some point he will have f4
and also he has the very strong a4
so basically the simplest idea is we're
gonna march our king over to the queen
side play a4 create a pass pawn here
and then leave the black king uh you
know uh struggling with the defense
of the uh well our our past pawn and
then we're just gonna use our king to
pick up all of the other pawns
to give you a really quick example the
game continued king of six king to g3
king to e6 and now magnus played king to
f3
and it was in this position uh on mu 48
that arado slavo tasha resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so that's all it takes to
you know be a great chess player uh even
though magnus could you know grab that
beep on and play a queen's end game
being up
two pawns he decided to go into a king
and opponent game being up only one pawn
because he knows his end games and he
knows that this is completely winning so
here eradic resigned
uh to give you a quick tour let's say
king d6 we're just going to march our
king all the way to the queen side king
e3
king to c6 doesn't matter what black
plays our plan is exactly the same
king d6 king c3 king c6 we're going to
play king to b3
and now after black plays whatever we're
going to play a4 so now
uh if black doesn't capture we create a
pass pawn here
uh and there's not all that much you can
do or
you know we can just play a5 create a
pass pawn shift our king over here then
play f4 and then we're definitely
breaking through
so here the game might continue b
captures on a4 we're going to play king
captures king a6 and now b5 check king
b6 we're gonna grab the opposition
and now black can either lose the uh
opposition or
try and waste the move but we can also
waste the move we're gonna play f3 king
b7 now king c5
and that's it we just start grabbing all
of these pawns and then of course it's
completely winning
so radek knows this and after king 2f3
he resigned the game and it's magnus who
goes into round five of the video world
cup and we'll see what happens next
i think he faces i don't want to lie to
you so i'm gonna check
um i'm pretty sure who he's facing but
uh let me just check real quickly uh
there we go yeah he faces andre acipenko
so it's gonna be a really awesome match
i have no doubt and
we're gonna check it out what happened
so 30 players
32 players are no more now there are 16
and we'll see who will emerge
victorious in the video world cup 2021.
uh so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it really a nice one and really
uh you know a sad sad story of the night
stuck on a6
and uh there was never really a reason
for the knight to come to a6 he could
have just played knight to c6 and the
uh all the same tactics apply white can
never capture on b7
and the knight would just be much better
place than you know would have a better
game
but here knight to a6 was played and uh
as of this moment magnus you know
uh uh you know planned his entire game
against the knight weirdly placed on a6
and that was
that was all it took to take down uh
radik who who
uh confronted magnus very nicely in the
classical time section but
you know in the rapids it simply wasn't
uh it wasn't enough and
this knight on a6 was was you know the
the the last straw
uh so once again hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank
steven binder uh amit gopal hatimare uh
yanderoyta happy birthday granky and
miha kennedy for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day